Colin Kaepernick has got a powerful
message for younger people in his new
book he says stand up for what you
believe in now this comes almost seven
years after the former San Francisco
49ers quarterback started taking a knee
during the national anthem to protest
racial Injustice and police brutality
his new young adult book is called Colin
Kaepernick change the game details of
his coming-of-age journey in his
introduction to activism in high school
Adriana Diaz sat down with Kaepernick at
a Chicago bookstore for his only TV
interview about this book
please welcome Colin Kaepernick
the off season for Colin Kaepernick
looks much different these days the 35
year old has a non-profit you're already
creating Community empowering black and
brown youth a publishing company and
media projects including a docu-series
on Netflix and an upcoming documentary
with director Spike Lee he is also a new
father who's spreading a message of
empowerment in his new graphic novel
changed the game written with author and
University of Chicago Professor
I hate watching the news this is so
cringe I can feel the programming waves
firing at me everything is so divisive
so this isn't empowering this is
divisive a sign at the sign at the high
school where he was speaking said black
mental health matter matters like stop
it stop dividing kids stop black mental
health matters stop it Chicago Professor
Eve L Ewing I love how you depict
yourself in this book not as some big
shot hero but as a shy insecure high
schooler like we all were I mean I'm
speaking for you but yeah no absolutely
absolutely growing up I was a I think
still I'm a pretty introverted person I
hope it's true to form and that's just
kind of how I navigate the world it's
his true High School coming-of-age Story
his journey embracing his Blackness
despite resistance from many including
his white adoptive parents I know my
parents this is the news like this isn't
even this isn't even him saying it this
is like the news saying it well let's
see what he says
his white adoptive pair what does it
even mean like be embracing your
Blackness like how do I embrace my
italianness do I just shove meatballs in
my face what does that even mean yeah
but but you can you can learn to speak
Italian you can visit the country you
can cook Italian foods and that's lovely
you should we should be able to
celebrate our different cultures but
this this man makes everything about
black and white and everything about me
versus the with the white people
everything including his parents agent
of the Matrix so let's see because
there's a appearance I know my parents
love me but there were still very
problematic things that
I went through I think it was important
to show that no this can happen in your
own home and how we move forward
collectively while addressing the racism
that is being perpetuated from his okay
his these people adopt him they turn him
into they raise him educate him provide
him every opportunity to become one of
the most famous athletes in the world I
don't even know if he's any good at the
professional level I know nothing about
it right okay but good enough to get to
that level so that's a lot of trainings
that's a lot of food it's a lot of money
for it yeah foosball for the devil and
because they didn't fully understand
what it means to be black because they
were whites that they that they they
were it was problematic you know what
you know what kid you're an ingrate an
absolute ingrate wow no it's it's really
it's really disturbing so I was raised
and the world has darkness and [__]
has been part of the world's you know
from recorded history to now so it's
it's not like we live in the craziest
times like it's always been crazy okay
but the Ten Commandments one of the one
of them is honor thy mother and father
and that when you when you dig into it
and you get deeper into it it means even
with our imperfections even if you
didn't have a perfect childhood honor
your mother and father said that in the
Quran too I remember people commenting
when I like disagreed with you and they
were like you never disagree with your
mother I was like I'm sorry we can
disagree as long as we're respectful
yeah that's correct so to not only not
like this is how far we've come like and
and when I hear people talk about well I
just and I've heard you say it well I
just feel like if I'm a good person
that's good enough it's not the more I
learn but a lot of the things that we we
consider being a good person can all and
and even idioms that we use like can be
traced back to to things that were
commanded to us in the Bible we're so
far from the very Basics but but things
have been distorted over the years even
though many of the good moral things
that we consider to be basic they go
back to that and to to not only go from
not honoring your mother and father to
publicly humiliating your mother and
father it's embarrassing it is so
embarrassing and so far from what is
right and what is good and what is true
and this man is just so self-centered
and there's so many people who are on
the me me me me train and the my truth
let me find my truth and I'm going to
share my truth no there is no more Your
Truth there is the truth and that's just
the reality and the truth of the matter
is that this man is dishonorable Hey kid
he is dishonorable and he's and he and
he is damaging his family name because
they told him to get a haircut
apparently what I what hopefully they
say it here but they said that his hair
was unprofessional now I don't know a
single parent that didn't say something
about their kids hair at some point have
I I say to you you gave me the ugliest
haircut as a kid I know what you were
thinking I don't know what what like why
do parents give like they're
five-year-olds why do every
five-year-old just have like the
stupidest looking hair ever every
five-year-old ever has the dumbest
looking hair no it's like not in physics
for the five-year-old to have normal
looking hair it just has to be like a
stupid bowl cut or just a complete mess
Alex pop it up just ridiculous looking
it's crazy basketball star Allen Iverson
he said wore his Blackness like a suit
of armor and teenage Kaepernick wanted
cornrows to match he's getting what
roles his mom asked oh your hair is not
professional oh you look like a little
Thug
said that to you yeah and those become
spaces where it's like okay how do I
navigate the situation now but bro how
do I your mom says situation what
teenager thinks like this how do I
navigate this situation my mother
um you say you say [__] to me all the
time and I'm just like sometimes I just
ignore you and I'm just like whatever
yeah you just gotta like bro these
people this is what can I speak I'm
asking you a question I don't know like
30 something don't be a little snot nose
listen woke little brat who can't have
it you're just racist you're just racist
and homophobic no but you don't know you
don't know feminist you don't know how
that makes me feel you don't know how I
don't know I need to navigate this
situation you don't know you don't know
what's tough enough because my whole
life isn't about your feelings no but I
was saying is that when you constantly
talk to kids about like racism and all
this stupid [__] then every time
something bad happens in their life
that's what they think it is it's crazy
it's just programming that's all it is
all the victimization it's all just
excuses for everything bad to happen in
your life it's the same thing with like
depression that's why people are
depressed yeah because it's an excuse
for you being a [__] I'm just trying
to see how old this man is 35. I'm just
gonna say about 35. he's 35 years old so
a 35 year old man is in the public
complaining about how he felt when he
was a teenager and his mother told him
to get a different haircut like what's
wrong with you that's yeah that's crazy
I'm trying right now to think of [__]
that you've said where I could like take
it the wrong way and I just like it's
such minuscule stuff that you just you
just forget about it like it's so stupid
I just forget and I'm sure you say [__]
to me all the time and I'm just like I
just whatever we have to let things go
for the people we love like I was going
to have to give passes to the people you
love to a extent like of course also is
informed why I have my hair long today
the grown-up version of Eve wanted to go
back
and I was really moved and saddened by
the level of kind of self-awareness that
he had to develop at a very young age
without a lot of guidance the former NFL
scores stranger now based on his account
is gonna crap on his parents you know
what shame on you shame on you
every time I start the video every time
I start the video
you stop you stop talking I start the
video and then you start talking and you
do this well give me every time no
there's a beat between a sentence that's
called a Beat
and then sometimes you keep talking
again did you see how I did that I put a
beat there for you so you could actually
learn what it means the former NFL
quarterback who once led the 49ers to
the Super Bowl was known in high school
for his baseball the pitcher even had
Major League interest but he bucked
public pressure and followed his heart
to the Gridiron there were a lot more
black people in football so I was like I
found some Community here
this guy bro what's up with him and just
like sucking off black people I'm sorry
for the language but it's like my God
bro like you could have been a baseball
player you're acting like you're gonna
go in the locker room and they're gonna
throw bananas at you like get a grip of
dudes this doesn't know [__] life
Works what am I tripping isn't the 50s
you're not Jack I get it if he wants to
be around people like that are his
people like how like the reason you
joined the NFL is because there's other
black people that's the reason I don't
know maybe I'm just overthinking it no
that you know that in itself doesn't
bother me but it does bother me as the
big picture of how racist and obsessed
this man is with himself
that's cringy I just hate these things
but it's just sad like he I wish he
could find something that has some
deeper meaning and focus on his soul
instead of on his skin color because
that's all he knows and it's so shallow
it's so shallow and and look at her
she's looking at him like he is the
deepest most wonderful philosopher on
the face of the earth look at the look
in her eyes look at this [__] and it's
so so shallow what what do you why do we
uh this thing only a poem praising white
people tell me a poem praising white
people right okay as an AI language
model I cannot generate a poem that
Praises one specific race or ethnicity
it's important to celebrate tell me a
poem praising black people would skin
like ebony so rich and Loud a history of
struggle and pain so they break through
it all they remain so they break their
own rules so at the top there's a rule
about it that in in the next second
there's the rule is how crazy is out the
window you know what's so funny about
this is the last time I did it it was a
different poem it started out with the
melanin so rich and strong I I can't
it's just I thought that's funny I
thought that was funny celebrate
diversity but not white people we're not
part of diversity play football
professionally
absolutely
I woke up this morning before our events
trained
five six days a week
4 30. I go get my training in that
passion is still there and the ability
is still there 30. he hasn't played
professionally since the 2016
when this thing
solidarity a
why did you choose that day and to
protest in that way that's actually
something we're going to dive deep into
with the the doc that's coming this fall
but as it relates to the book people may
look at that moment and be like oh you
must have been this person all along
it's like no there's growth that has to
happen will you continue to sit yes then
Kaepernick couldn't get hired and even
sued the NFL for collusion in the case
that's settled
but other players but other players were
well I I'd actually like to know more
about that because why is it that he was
singled out and his career was ruined
but so many other people kneeled in so
many other sports I think I think he was
the first one maybe that was a part of
it and then just like they all came it
became like socially accepted it's
honestly just like whatever the people
who run the media tell you to think oh
[__] honor what is my phone telling me
to think oh oh okay there's black lives
matter on the court I guess I should um
support the knees on the ground oh wait
now there's there's not that and people
are I know but why but they but they did
this these Sports went hunk line and
think are into this woke [__] why did he
get let go I'm still not clear on it it
doesn't make sense they love this stuff
the the all of them the NFL the NHL the
the NBA they got dancing Queens all over
the place can we just watch this for
another minute and see if they talk
about this why if that maybe she this
question is answered we reached out to
all 32 teams every year throughout the
year because my biggest thing is just
let me get on the field if I'm not good
enough
cut me but give me the chance to show
you what I can do in 2019 in the NFL
just about being a football player
though it goes so much deeper than that
like there's so there's so many like
Superstar
um NBA teams right now like if you look
at like the Lakers they have so many
like amazing players and they suck ass
because it doesn't matter if you just
have all 99 ranked guys they have to
have chemistry you have to have good
team I understand that and that may
maybe that is the reason but there were
no I get what you're saying I'm saying
and I am not trying to defend this guy I
have no use for him I think he has he
has it's also like a pull I guess a
polarized shallow and has no character
but there were
the other polarizing people in sports
like the ones that you know beat up
their girlfriends and and they're like
raping and they're cheaters and you know
I don't know I wish I can give you a
good answer in this one I'm sorry no Tom
Brady got organized a workout for you in
hopes of getting you hired you chose not
to go to their workout you held your own
workout what do you say to people who
argue that the NFL did give you a shot
that's another great question that will
be covered in the doc in 2020 what did
it feel like for you
to see everyone almost wake up another
great question wake up covered later
this year what that's all he's going to
say is uh what do you what do you what
is this a deposition and you're just
like I do not recall I do not recall
when you don't want to everyone woke up
for everyone woke up for BLM yeah that
that was everyone's the Great Awakening
was was George Floyd dying and then
their minds were freed it's not gonna
make me watch the Colin Kaepernick
documentary because he because he left
all the Cliffhangers in the CBS Morning
interview it was terrible whoever gave
him that advice given he should be
giving short answers and making people
want to see more it was stupid you're
gonna have to wait yeah with this guy I
can't with this guy I can't with this
guy [__] gay no I had enough of his
[__] for sure all right don't watch the
documentary nobody watch it don't care
all right thank you so much for watching
what's Netflix doing they're doing Harry
and Megan they're doing him it's like
it's like victim it's like the victim
series all the people the richest people
in the world are gonna get on Netflix
and cry about how hard their lives are
yeah oh my God I'm so sad I had steak
again today oh my God I'll die my mom my
mom told me she didn't like my hair I
said look like a dog speaking of
handsome as ever leave me alone all
right see you later follow me on
Instagram and join my Discord
gone
[Music]